[Music]
chris is with us in detroit michigan hi
chris welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me sure what's
up
uh so my question is
me and my girlfriend are looking to get
married
in the next few years here
and we don't really have a ton of money
or assets to do that with
neither of us has any debt but we're
wondering
what we can do
um with like
like a wedding coming up
maybe a house or rental or whatever we
do
what kind of um
money we should have saved before we try
to go ahead with getting married
how old are you
20.
and uh what do you do for a living
currently
i'm a manager at fast food joint
um
i've been applying a lot to get
something in my field
what is your field i have
bioengineering
and you have a four-year degree
uh not yet i'm working on the last year
of it okay
all right
all right cool
and uh yeah that would certainly pay
more than managing a fast food operation
right
yeah it should yeah what do you make now
um
15 an hour okay what does she make
uh hers is a little spottier
she's in school right now for nursing
um and she's doing clinicals and will be
doing
further more like paid um
whatever it's called when will she
graduate
she'll graduate
um in 2023.
okay
all right and you live with your parents
she lives with hers or what yep
okay
all right when are you thinking of
getting married
um honestly as soon as possible but we
didn't want to be reckless about it
either okay
well i think if you're gonna do it as
soon as possible you have a very minor
low budget wedding
which there's no shame in by the way
lots of people have low budget weddings
and have wonderful lives
you know there's no correlation between
the expense of the wedding and the
success of the marriage
no statistical evidence of that okay nor
the size of the ring in the marriage
uh so um i mean you guys can lay that
out and say okay we're gonna budget for
this and then we're gonna get a little
apartment and we're gonna put some used
furniture in it
and uh we're gonna be able to pay our
bills with the work that we have
and we're going to have to work extra
jobs and you know make do things to make
ends meet but you're not buying a house
right now you're going to get her
through nursing school and we're going
to get you in your career long term
but um
i mean if you can work 60 hours at 15
and she can work uh uh some hours and
keep going while she's going through
nursing school you can probably pay for
a little apartment and
you know just get started with your
lives and have a low budget wedding
again some family and friends and pick
some flowers out of the field right
um put cook some hamburgers on the grill
it does not you know
being married does not require a big
fancy you know i spent 100 000 to get
married it's not necessary uh if you
want to you can
but um but but not
um
not otherwise so uh it just depends on
again so i and the way you do this is
you just back in you say okay uh it's uh
it's christmas we want to get married to
september
and between now and then we've got to
save up the money to pay our deposits on
an apartment uh get utilities turned on
we have to work our budgets out make
sure we can do that and we've got to
save up some money to have whatever
level of wedding we're going to have and
you start laying it out you go okay we
can save 200 a month and that's nine
months so we can have you know a couple
thousand dollars to spend on a little
wedding and you lay it out that way
figure out what you can do and back into
the goals
and then you can decide you know what
your timeline is that's reasonable so
hey good question man hope it works out
for you this is the ramsey show